[Música]
y centró buena parte de su campaña en
atacar el libre comercio y denunciar la
supuesta competencia desleal de países
como méjico y sobre todo china sí amigos
en otros vídeos anteriores ya contamos
que china fue tan importante en su
discurso electoral que prácticamente
podemos referirnos a trump como el
candidato anti china camps se
comprometió a poner fin al papel del
gigante asiático como la fábrica del
mundo y traer de vuelta a los eeuu
fábricas y empleos fijando aranceles
altísimos a los productos chinos ahora
bien muchas de sus tesis se basan en
planteamientos erróneos y desatar una
guerra comercial con china tendría para
los eeuu consecuencias muy graves
[Música]
nos quitan nuestros trabajos destruyen
nuestras fábricas manipulan su moneda
ejercen la competencia desleal son solo
algunos de los mensajes que donald trump
utilizó sistemáticamente para denunciar
el modelo de crecimiento chino durante
una campaña en la que se llegó a referir
a este país como el ladrón más grande de
todos los tiempos
sainz grave por contra el suéter joe
este quite staff en 2007 bueno hoy
sabemos que esta estrategia funciona
según las llamadas exit polls o
encuestas a pie de urna y diversos
estudios llevados a cabo tras la campaña
muchos electores apostaron por donald
trump porque éste les ofrecía una
solución clara un problema que muchos
estadounidenses padecen la pérdida de
empleo en la industria manufacturera y
es que en las tres últimas décadas en
eeuu ha aprendido más de un tercio de
todos los empleos industriales sólo
desde el año 2000 varios millones de
trabajadores han perdido su puesto de
trabajo en fábricas que pagaban 25
dólares la hora y que en la mayoría de
los casos sólo pueden encontrar la
salida en empleos del sector servicios
donde los salarios no
y la mitad james el mayor productor
mundial de ketchup despedirá a mil 350
trabajadores en eeuu y canadá
el mensaje es el siguiente si
restringimos el acceso de productos
chinos si terminamos con su competencia
desleal' nuestras fábricas volverán a
florecer y con ellas los puestos de
trabajo se multiplicarán una idea que
también ha utilizado como sabéis con
méxico
ahora bien que es de verdad en todo esto
la importancia del mercado chino
si echamos un vistazo rápido a las
estadísticas comerciales podríamos
llegar a pensar que donald trump está en
lo cierto al año las compras de eeuu a
china superan en más de 350 mil millones
de dólares a las ventas de tal forma que
atentos ese déficit comercial supone
casi tanto como la mitad de todas las
exportaciones de latinoamérica al resto
del mundo tran culpó a china de ser el
causante de la mitad del déficit
comercial de eeuu y afirmó que el país
asiático no es una economía de mercado
bueno este dato para que dar la razón a
la tesis de que china está secando a los
estados unidos pues espérate un momento
porque esto no es así del todo las
exportaciones chinas hacia américa no
son exclusivamente de productos de
empresas chinas de hecho más de la mitad
de todas las exportaciones chinas a eeuu
corresponden bien a productos de
empresas estadounidenses viene a
productos que éstas necesitan para
completar su producción en los eeuu me
explico pongamos como ejemplo el caso de
apple cada iphone que se produce en
china es exportado a los eeuu
aproximadamente por un valor de 180
dólares
ahora bien previamente china tuvo que
importar 172 dólares en componentes de
otros países como por ejemplo corea del
sur japón alemania o los propios eeuu el
resultado es que el ensamblaje en china
solo aportó 8 dólares al valor del
producto pero las estadísticas de eeuu
lo recogen por 180 distorsionando así la
realidad de las relaciones comerciales y
por supuesto tanto los beneficios como
los mejores puestos de trabajo se quedan
en los eeuu puede ser que a veces no lo
veas pero siempre podrás sentirlo
esta es nuestra firma
y significa todo
por otra parte la tendencia está
cambiando y desde 2005 las exportaciones
de eeuu a china se han triplicado el
cliente escéptico compra como loco
aviones de boeing coches de general
motors ropa de nike o miles de toneladas
de café de starbucks tan solo en el caso
de apple china genera el 20 por ciento
del negocio mundial 53 mil millones cada
año la guerra comercial prometida por
trump podría tener un efecto devastador
sobre las compañías estadounidenses y
por extensión sobre la economía porque a
él le quepa la menor duda de que china
respondería inmediatamente y las
empresas de eeuu perderían el acceso a
un mercado de más de 1.300 millones de
personas menudo negocio y es que amigos
de visual política el proteccionismo
nunca ha funcionado y la verdad
difícilmente esta vez será diferente la
pérdida de poder de consultas en los
efectos no terminan de cumplirse las
amenazas de trump hacia china los
primeros damnificados serían los propios
ciudadanos estadounidenses especialmente
la clase media y las personas con menos
recursos
y la sustitución de productos y
componentes fabricados en china
elevarían los costes de las empresas y
con ello los precios de venta de una
infinidad de productos el resultado el
desplome en la capacidad de consumo de
la mayoría de los estadounidenses entre
ellos por supuesto de los propios
votantes de trans y encima las grandes
marcas del país perderían capacidad
competitiva respecto a las de otros
países así no resulta extraño que el
wall street journal alerta de una
posible recesión si trump cumple su
palabra la guerra inútil pero es que
además donald trump basa sus
planteamientos en una gran mentira la
pérdida de poder industrial de los eeuu
lo que es absolutamente falso es verdad
desde los 80 un momento de empleo récord
en el sector en eeuu han desaparecido
más de 7 millones de empleos
industriales pero eso no quiere decir
que haya ocurrido lo mismo con la
producción de hecho desde ese año la
producción industrial real se ha más que
duplicado y hoy en día se encuentra sólo
ligeramente por debajo del pico máximo
que se alcanzó en 2000
con sus aviones madeinusa airways espera
reducir costos y hacer más competitivos
sus precios dado que en alabama el
salario mínimo es de 75 dólares la hora
uno de los más bajos del país es decir
no es que eeuu haya perdido capacidad
industrial es que hoy es mucho más
fuerte en este ámbito el problema no es
china sino que las fábricas ya no
necesitan emplear a tanta gente como
antes porque buena parte del trabajo
está automatizado general motors sin
duda una de las corporaciones más
emblemáticas del país funciona hoy con
aproximadamente una tercera parte de los
más de 600 mil trabajadores que tuvo en
los 70 y aún así produce más automóviles
y camiones que nunca
eso es el medio
operation desarrollo
[Música]
muy bueno
un poco esto no quiere decir que hoy no
hay trabajo en eeuu todo lo contrario
hoy trabaja en este país más gente que
en cualquier otro momento de la historia
lo que ocurre es que estamos viviendo un
cambio de paradigma que nos obliga a
adaptarnos pero que nadie se confunda el
pasado no va a regresar en resumen
podemos enviar directamente a la
papelera
el discurso de trampa dificultar el
comercio con china en méxico y supongo
que también con otras potencias
industrias emergentes como vietnam no
sólo no serviría para nada sino que
además podría destruir millones de
puestos de trabajo adicionales y
dificultar la adaptación necesaria al
nuevo paradigma económico hacia el que
nos encaminamos
[Música]
de estrategia en el pacífico
en la misma línea también podemos
determinar que no parece una estrategia
acertada demoler el buen trabajo que
obama haber llevado a cabo en el
pacifico donald trump ha decidido de
forma coherente con sus tesis
proteccionistas tumbar el acuerdo de
libre comercio más grande de todos los
tiempos que afectaba a más del 40 por
ciento del pib global y que suponía una
oportunidad extraordinaria para que las
empresas estadounidenses hubiesen
generado millones de nuevos puestos de
trabajo el presidente electo de eeuu
donald trump anunció que en su primer
día de gobierno va a iniciar el proceso
para que su país se salga del acuerdo de
asociación transpacífico el famoso té pp
por sus siglas en inglés
algunos estudios hablan de que las
exportaciones de eeuu hubiesen crecido
en más de 350.000 millones de dólares al
tiempo que los consumidores hubiesen
incrementado su capacidad de compra y
las empresas sus beneficios de momento
mientras eeuu decide tumbar muchas de
las políticas que lo convirtieron en el
país más rico de la tierra china el gran
enemigo de trump mueve ficha y se
dispone a liberar su propia de pepe de
impulsar la zona de libre comercio
asia-pacífico construir una economía
mundial abierta
y hacer mayores contribuciones a la
estabilidad y prosperidad de nuestro
mundo de forma contraria a sus promesas
el legado de trans puede ser el de un
eeuu mucho más decadente y menos
competitivo es decir el resultado
opuesto a las esperanzas de una gran
parte de sus votantes bien espero que te
resultado interesante este vídeo he sido
así
no olvides suscribirte a visual político
dando click aquí si aún no lo has hecho
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]